the science of climate change is really
confusing I mean even right now people
are like wait we have record snow levels
there it's not global warming it's
actually cooling and throughout excuse
me history there are these fluctuations
but overall the last decade has been the
hottest on record this year will be the
hottest year on record overall so it's
kind of a big step to think okay it's
getting warmer the oceans are heating so
there's evaporation it's making more
clouds they travel over here and there's
more snow it's not it's not immediately
intuitive and that's the area that the
skeptics operate and they go for for the
knowing that the common person does not
understand that and does not understand
how that works and why is there more
drought and simultaneously more rain
storms and and that margin there is
where people are able to sort of live in
wallow and be but I say that with a
little bit of you know this guy but but
it's true and I think that there have
been a number of studies that have come
out as I was saying before that show
that the predictions are much worse than
what's in the film and you know what
people don't talk about which I wish
they would is okay so what if it isn't
is dire as we've been saying still why
would you want to spew all these
chemicals into the air where your
children are growing up I mean asthma
rates are one in three now it didn't
used to be like that it wasn't even like
that at the dawn of the Industrial
Revolution when things were initially
much dirtier I have met a number of
people that have said you know do I
believe that we moved the needle I think
in two thousand and six and seven we
definitely did now I still think there
are a lot of people that haven't seen
the movie I think it's an overwhelming
problem and people think even if i
change my light bulbs or i take public
transportation the same person in china
is not doing that so why should I bother
and I think that it's just an
overwhelming thing for people and that's
why we put the tips at the end of the
movie because you can't go out and
immediately you as an individual enact
legislation
but you can plant a tree you can you
know change your light bulbs you can
take public transportation and you can
write your congressperson and you can be
part of the political will that al talks
about because if we have that then
there's a chance we can change
everything else